[Music]
katy perry was a surprise guest last
night at the office Christmas party
premier check her out posing with
Jennifer Aniston wonder what they were
talking about cuz they both dated Johnny
I was gonna say but I'll tell you one
thing good they look great i mean
there's go all out am i right us so i
figured i had to step up my game I don't
know what they had to do or pay you to
make you wear that we're we're 10 this
whole thing so you saw the movie and
then said I will dress up like one of
the Karen no no it's a hat it's a hat
too much cat that just takes it too far
can I get a volleyball see I wasn't
kidding are rumors now like oh boy here
we go sumo snowmen was definitely the
way to go at least I didn't get a frosty
reception Cameron Entertainment Tonight
whose shoes boom it's gonna seen it this
is one of these things where you said
you know will be funny and then halfway
through you said oh yeah this kind of
sucks I I look like I should be standing
in front of our car dealership right
after this red carpet I'm gonna try and
say this seriously entertainment
tonight's office Christmas parties
happening like it's starting literally
right now what do I need to do oh what's
some advice you just got to have a
really good time you really have to and
remember everything cuz if you don't
remember then it probably didn't end too
well as we know you and Kevin Frazier
work together back in the day k Frey
will be there tonight oh nice i'm
something that i can know like on olivia
munn punk or challenge something I can
do or dare that's something I could do
with Kevin and then eventually say that
was from Olivia okay what are you
standing there just went to cici's legs
are locked just go by nizhny and just
like put in Hilda's kind of buckle
underneath do then just be like that's
from Olivia Munn and then walk away
right got it it's gonna happen unless
you said I'm not the kind of guy to say
no to a dare so I hit up the district
here in LA still in my soobak yeah old
man costume by the way and this happen
ok
what that wasn't gonna hit took me down
I just want to say that that moment was
fueled by um casa mexico tequila that
made that bad as possible I'm okay
everybody I'm okay but the Snowman soon
will never be the same
[Music]
you